turning now to another deadly mass
shooting over the weekend here we go
again this time at a southern california
church
one person was killed and five wounded
but this one could have been much much
worse parishioners at geneva
presbyterian church that's in laguna
woods hogtied and detained the alleged
gunman in this shooting after he opened
fire police say those parishioners
showed exceptional heroism their words
carter evans is outside the church with
more on the heroes and how they stopped
this shooting carter good morning to you
good morning gail investigators say
about 30 to 40 parishioners were
gathered for lunch at after the morning
church service when the gunfire erupted
now the orange county under sheriff said
if it wasn't for a group of what he
called hero parishioners tackling the
gunman well more people could have died
we believe a group of churchgoers
detained him and hog tied his legs with
an extension cord and confiscated at
least two weapons from him he was
detained when the deputies arrived
two firearms were recovered at the scene
the suspect is an asian man in his 60s
he's not believed to live in the area
investigators are working to determine
if he has any connections to the church
or its congregants now the six victims
who were shot are all asian and they
range in age from 66 to 92 years old one
person was killed the others were
critically injured except for one who
had just a minor injury now a church
representative said they were all
honoring a former pastor who was
visiting from taiwan the fbi and atf are
now investigating and by the way nate a
congr
a a congregant says it was that visiting
pastor who grabbed a chair when the
gunman was reloading and hit him on the
head with it and that's when the other
church goers tackled him
a hero indeed carter thank you